the same desire to behold the various
kingdoms of the world which is urged on
others
excited me also to a similar enterprise
i deliberated in my own mind that i
should see those which had been least
frequented by the venetians
wherefore spreading our sails to a
favorable wind and having implored
the divine aid we committed ourselves to
the sea
when we came to alexandria a city of
egypt i longing for novelty
as a thirsty man longs for fresh water
departed from these places
as being well known to all and entering
the nile
arrived at cairo on my arrival to cairo
i who had been
previously much astonished at the
account of its size came to the
conclusion that it was not so large as
it had been reported to be
but its size and circumference is about
equal to that of rome
i say nothing about the riches and
beauty of the aforesaid cairo and the
pride of the mammalouks because they are
well known to our countrymen
so i sailed thence into syria and went
towards damascus which is distant 10
short days journey
and onwards
in 1503 on the 8th day of april the
caravan being set in order to go to
mecca
and i being desirous of beholding
various scenes and not knowing how to go
about it
formed a great friendship with the
captain of the mamalux of the caravan
who was a christian renegade so that he
clothed me like her mama luke and gave
me a good horse
and placed me in company with other mama
looks and this was accomplished by means
of the money and other things which i
gave him
and in this manner we set ourselves on
the way
arriving at the city which is called
medina thal nabi
now some who say that the body of mahmet
is suspended in the air at mecca
must be reproved i i say that is not
true i've seen his sepulcher in this
city
midi nathal nabi in which we remained
three days
and wished to see everything the first
day we went into the city
at the entrance by the door of their
mosque and each of us
small or great was obliged to be
accompanied by some person
within there is a sepulchre that is a
pit underground
wherein was placed mahmet we remained
there three days in order to give rest
to the camels
now being tired of these things we
prepared ourselves to pass onwards
to mecca
this video is sponsored by skillshare
the online learning platform
since production started on longer
documentaries i've been using skillshare
to hone my skills to really maximize
their potential
one great example was the class learn
premiere pro
with hallease navias a great class that
helped me raise my level on the software
needed for a youtube channel
and that's skillshare whether you're a
professional or just starting out it's a
great resource for self-improvement
and a great place to spark ideas with
thousands of classes fit for any
schedule
and to start you off the first thousand
of my subscribers to click the link in
the description
will get a free trial of premium
membership so you can explore your
creativity
and make the most of 2021 thanks
[Music]
we will now speak of the very noble city
of mecca
what it is its state and who governs it
the city is most beautiful
and it is very well inhabited and
contains about six thousand families
the houses are extremely good like our
own and there are houses worth three or
four thousand ducats each
the city is not surrounded by walls a
quarter of a mile distant from the city
we found a mountain
where there was a road cut by human
labor and then we descended into the
plain
the walls of the said city are the
mountains and it has four entrances
the governor of this city is a sultan
that is one of the four brothers
and is of the race of mahmet and is
subject to the grand sultan
of cairo his three brothers are always
at war with him
we entered from the north and afterwards
we descended into the plain
on the side towards the south there are
two mountains which almost touch each
other
where is the past to go to the gate of
mecca on the other side where the sun
rises
there is another mountain pass like a
valley through which is the road to the
mountain where they celebrate the
sacrifice of
abraham and isaac which mountain is
distant from the said city about eight
or ten miles
the height of this mountain is two or
three casts of a stone by hand
you must know that i had excellent
experiences of these mammals during the
journey
amongst others i saw a mamaluke take one
of his slaves and place a pomegranate on
his head
and make him stand 12 or 15 paces
distance from him
and at the second trial strike off the
pomegranate by a shot from a bow
again i saw another mama luke running at
full gallop take off the saddle
and place it on his head and afterwards
return it to its original place
without falling
now let us return to the city you must
know that in my opinion
the curse of god has been laid upon the
said city
for the country produces neither grass
nor trees
nor anything and they suffer from so
great a dearth of water
that if everyone were to drink as much
as he might wish four cartrini worth of
water daily would not suffice them
i will tell you in what manner they live
a great part of their provisions come
from cairo that is from the red
sea there is a port called zida which is
distant from the said city 40 miles
a great quantity of food also comes
there from arabia felix
and also a great part comes from
ethiopia
we found a great number of pilgrims of
whom some came from ethiopia
some from india major some from india
minor some from persia and some from
syria
truly i never saw so many people
collected in one spot as during the 20
days i remained there
of these people some had come for the
purposes of trade and some
on pilgrimage for their pardon in which
pardon you shall understand
what they do
in the midst of the city there is a very
beautiful temple
similar to the colosseum of rome but not
made of such large stones
but of burnt bricks and it is round in
the same manner
it has 90 or 100 doors around it and is
arched
and has many of these doors on entering
the said temple
you descend 10 or 12 steps of marble and
here and there about the entrance there
stand men who sell
jewels and nothing else and when you
have descended the said steps you find
the temple all around and everything
that is the walls
covered with gold and under the arches
they stand about 4 000 or 5 000 persons
men and women which persons sell all
kinds of odoriferous things
the greater part are powders for
preserving human bodies
because pagans come there from all parts
of the world truly it would not be
possible to describe the sweetness of
the odours
which are smelt within this temple on
the 23rd of may the said pardon
commences in the above mentioned temple
the pardon is this within the said
temple and uncovered
in the centre there is a tower the size
of which is about five or six paces on
each side
around which tower there is a cloth of
black silk
and there is a door all of silver of the
height of a man
by which you enter into the said tower
on the 24th of may all the people begin
before day to go seven times around the
said tower
always touching and kissing each corner
and at about
10 or 12 paces distant from the said
tower there is another tower like a
chapel with three or four doors
in the center of the said tower there is
a very beautiful well which is 70
fathoms deep and the water is
brackish at this well there stands six
or eight men
appointed to draw water for the people
and those who draw the water
throw three buckets over each person
from the crown of their heads to their
feet
and all bathe even though their dress be
made of silk
and all having thus bathed they go by
the way of the valley to the said
mountain
of which we have before spoken and
remain there two days on one night
and when they are all at the foot of the
said mountain they make the sacrifice
there every man and woman kills at least
two or three
and some four and some six sheep
so that i really believe that on the
first day more than thirty thousand
sheep are killed
by cutting their throats facing the east
each person gives them to the poor for
the love of god there were about thirty
thousand poor people there
who made a very large hole in the earth
and put in it camels dung
and thus they made a little fire and
warmed the flesh a little
and then ate it and truly it is my
opinion
that these poor men came more on account
of their hunger than for the sake of the
pardon
and as a proof that it was so we had a
great number of cucumbers
which came from arabia felix and we ate
them all but the rind
which we afterwards threw away outside
our tent and about 40 or 50 of these
said poor people
stood before our tent and made a great
scrambling among themselves
in order to pick up the said rhines
which were full of sand
by this it appeared to us that they came
rather to satisfy their hunger
than to wash away their sins
in another part of the temple there is
an enclosed place in which there are two
live unicorns and these are shown as
very
remarkable objects which they certainly
are truly this
monster must be very fierce and solitary
animal these two animals were presented
to the sultan of mecca
as the finest things that could be found
in the world at the present day
and as the richest treasure ever sent by
the king of ethiopia that is
by a moorish king he made this present
in order to secure an alliance with the
said
sultan of mecca
i must here show how the human intellect
manifests itself under certain
conditions
insofar as it becomes necessary for me
to exercise it in order to escape
from the caravan of mecca having gone to
make some purchases for my captain
i was recognized by a moor who looked me
in the face and said to me
where are you from i answered
i am a moor he replied you are not
telling the truth
i said to him by the head of mahmet i am
a moor
he answered come to my house and i went
with him
when i had arrived at his house he spoke
to me in italian and told me where i had
come from
and that he knew i was not a moor when i
heard this i told him i was a roman
and that i had become a mama look at
cairo when he heard this he was much
pleased and treated me with great honor
i began to say to him if this
was the city of mecca which was so
renowned throughout all the world
where were the jewels and spices and
where are all the various kinds of
merchandise which it was reported they
brought here
i asked him this only that he might tell
me why
they had not arrived as usual and when
he told me that the king of portugal was
the cause i pretended to be much grieved
and spoke
great ill of the said king merely that
he might not think
that i was pleased that the christians
should make such a journey
when he saw that i displayed hostility
to the christians he showed me yet
greater honor
and told me everything point by point i
said to him friend i beg you
tell me some mode or way by which i may
escape from the caravan
because my intention is to go find those
beings who are hostile to the christians
hearing this he said mahmet be praised
who has sent us such a man to serve the
moors
and god so he concealed me in his house
with his wife when friday came
i set out with the caravan at noon to
the no small regret of the said ladies
who made great lamentations i cannot
express the kindness i received from
this lady and especially from her niece
of 15 years old
they promising me that if i would remain
there they would make me rich
but i declined all their offers on
account of the present danger
on saturday we departed and traveled
until midnight
when we entered into the port of the
city of zida
you